-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, let's get to
some news here.
Well, guys, this weekend,
former president Trump
closed out CPAC.
And at one point
during his speech,
he made some
pretty intense promises.
Watch this.
-Today, I add,
I am your warrior,
I am your justice,
and for those who have been
wronged and betrayed,
I am your retribution.
[ Laughter ]
-He's either running for
president or auditioning to be
the next John Wick.
He was like,
"I'm your retribution."
Then he kind of went
off the rails after that.
He's like,
"I'm the captain now.
I am the one who knocks.
I am the walrus.
Coo-coo-ca-choo."
Yep, Trump was the headliner
for the four-day event,
but it didn't look like
too many people
showed up for his speech.
Check out this shot
of the room that it was...
Oh, my gosh.
There's more people seated
at LaGuardia
for flights to Moscow right now.
It was so empty, the guy
started vacuuming because
he thought the event was over.
He's like, "No, no, he's..."
But Trump spoke
for almost two hours.
And, of course,
he had a few slip-ups.
But listen to this.
-...who is presiding over one of
the most dangerous and violent
cities in the United Straights.
You have to see this.
United States.
-Yeah, United Straits. Yeah.
Mike Pence heard
"United Straights"
and was like, "Hey,
that's my campaign slogan."
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
-Yeah, come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How do you mispronounce a word
that's in the job title
you're trying to get?
That's like going to
a job interview and like,
"I would make a great barista
here at Storebucks.
I would really..."
Yeah, that word was
giving Trump a lot of trouble,
'cause later in his speech,
he had a similar gaffe.
Watch this.
-And I'll challenge the
governors of all 50 spates --
all 50 states.
-"50 spates. All 50 spates.
From Pennessee
to New Ham Sandwich."
That's right -- Trump was the --
[ Laughter ]
Trump was the headliner at CPAC.
It was a big speech,
so his staff tried to keep him
on message by making him
use a teleprompter.
Yeah, so check out what
they were showing him
to keep him focused.
-Thank you very much.
And I'm thrilled to be back
at CPAC with thousands of
great and true
American patriots.
We shut down the illegal
foreign invasion at our borders.
We deported
illegal criminal aliens.
I built hundreds of miles
of wall.
We're going to do another
200 miles of wall.
Under my leadership,
we will seal it up.
I will stop Joe Biden's
demolition of our economy
with his crushing inflation.
They know that,
when we return to power,
we will bring their lies
and their corruption
and their disinformation
tumbling down.
-Yeah, yeah.
You have to keep him --
keep him focused.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, I saw that today is
National Dentist's Day,
everybody.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's celebrated once a year,
although dentists would prefer
once every six months.
Yep, 4 out of 5 dentists
celebrated today,
while that one dentist
really can't
get on board with anything.
Well, get this.
There's a limited-edition
Girl Scouts Cookie
called the Raspberry Rally,
and it sold out so quickly
that boxes are now being listed
on eBay for hundreds of dollars.
That's a great way for
Girl Scouts to earn their
black-market badge.
What's going in America?
You can buy legal weed
in a store,
but you've got to go underground
for Girl Scout Cookies.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, finally, before we move on,
I'd like to take a moment
to thank some of our sponsors
for "The Tonight Show."
They don't always fit
in commercial breaks,
and we want to make sure
that we mention all of them.
It's time for
"Tonight Show Sponsors."
♪♪
-♪ "Tonight Show" Sponsors" ♪
♪ "Tonight Show" Sponsors" ♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally...
That's all for
"Tonight Show Sponsors."